also unsere letzte Sitzung ist ja nicht ganz ideal
verlaufen und deswegen durften sie heute jemanden
mitbringen und sie haben sich entschieden für den
Herrn habbeck und zwar weil sie glauben dass der
Herr habbeck mitschuldig ist am Erstarken der
AFD das ist interessant was sagen sie denn dazu
Herr [Musik] habik Herr habbeck sorry ich bin nur
kurz eingent ich habe nich nicht geschlafen seit
2021 da sehen sie es ich bin in Lebensgefahr und
er pennt Entschuldigung wer wup denn hier multiple
Krisen ja also Krieg Energie Klima und wird
gleichzeitig von der AFC zum Staatsfeind Nummer
1 hochgejest ich das ist spannend die fühlen sich
also beide bedroht von der AFD ich ich mache mal
einen Vorschlag ja wie wär es denn dann mit einem
gemeinsamen Verbotsantrag gut also Verbot da bin
ich vorsichtig se nach dem letzten angeblichen
heizungsverbot von mir da also da nicht da
sind meine Umfragewerte in dem Keller in den ich
angeblich jeder Nacht steige um den deutschen mit
meinem heizungshammer höchstpönlich die Ölheizung
rauszuschweißen man kann mit einem Hammer nicht
ich ich ich habe hier einen Zitat ich ein kluger
Mann hat mal gesagt Verbote sind Bedingung für
Freiheit ja gut das kann nur jemand gesagt haben
der keinerlei politische Verantwortung hat ja das
Zitat ist von Ihnen Herr habbeck zwar von 2019
ja gut damals war ich auch noch wach seh sie
seh sie heutzutage setzen wir außerdem z.B beim
Klimaschutz nicht so sehr auf Verbote mehr so auf
den steigenden CO2 Preis mhm vielleicht ist genau
das das Problem was hast du jetzt gen steigen CO2
Preis das ist gut fürs Klima ja gar nichts aber
immer wenn du einen auf Öko machst wer am Schluss
ich verprügelt na das ist schon interessant was
sagen Sie zu diesem Vorwurf ich sag ja auch immer
muss den man muss dem Unmut der der Bevölkerung
also wirklich schnell den Wasserhahn abdrehen
also den den blauen und und mE auch den roten sie
haben natürlich eine Mischbatterie zu Hause was
natlich ökologisch nicht so sinnvoll ist weil sie
dann heißes Wasser mit kaltem Wasser mischen und
natürlich wegen der Legionären ist es vernünftig
einmal am Tag auf 60° zu erhitzen wie war noch
mal die Frage da sehen sie es da sehen sie es da
sehen sie es da sehen sie es Stellen frage ich
ich bin in Lebensgefahr und erst beim Duschen ich
sehe mich ja selber eher als Team Waschlappen ja
ja Waschlappen äh ich würde mal versuchen das was
ich gehört habe zusammenzufassen man darf bei den
Maßnahmen das soziale nicht vergessen da na so wä
es auch gegangen nicht W aber fragen Sie ihn doch
mal ob er die Vermögenssteuer wieder einführen
will Herr hab wollen sie die Vermögenssteuer
wieder einführen ja das das n n weil da macht
der Christian nicht mit Erbschaftssteuer reden
sie gern miteinander planst du vielleicht eine
Erhöhung der Erbschaftssteuer der Christian kein
Fan von wie den be deiner Vermögensabgabe aus
kenst chr also ich muss sagen ich hö jetzt hier
diesen Namen Christian ja für den macht er alles
und für mich nichts nicht mal eine Klitz kleine
Umverteilung das überhaupt nicht wahr das als
es kommt ja z.B das klimageld das ist ja so
ein sozialer ausgleichmechanismus für höhere CO2
Preise das steht sogar im Koalitionsvertrag das
kommt das ist klar wie klusbrühe obwohl ich jetzt
ich zugeben muss persönlich keine klare klosbrühe
kenne weil na ja allein schon durch den Klos
durchzuschauen das ist ja auch schwer möglich
ja ja aber das ist doch ein toller Vorschlag ja er
kann ih auch er kann ihn auch ganz toll erklären
warum das kommen muss vielleicht mit einer
Metapher Robert ja gerne wenn ich soll also also
seh sie wenn man also wenn kein Ausgleich erfolgt
sozial D dann haben sie haben sie quasi Menschen
die am Rad drehen die sind frustrierter als ochen
ochsenbraderei haben sie quasi ein Volksfest der
demokratiefeindlichkeit der versstehst du ih
Ideologie am Ende sogar wenn es hochkommt hab
Feindlichkeit und ich sage deswegen ist ja ein
klimageld ist natürlich die entscheidende Maßnahme
um da rausz h hören Sie die entscheidende Maßnahme
habe ich gehört ja ich habe dann die entscheidende
Frage Herr habbeck wann soll es denn kommen
was na das klimageld ach al ja klar LOGI ja das
Finanzministerium ist eben gerade dabei sag mal
den auszahlungsmechanismus zu zu zu programmieren
da ist er wieder der Christian es ist halt n mal
so der christian hat ganz klar gesagt sagt nicht
das mit den Überweisungen an die Bürgerin ist
gestaltet sich schwierig in die andere Richtung
funktioniert seit Jahrhunderten aber ziemlich
reibungslos oder in Österreich hat man gerade mal
Monate gebraucht für ein klimabonus und bei
uns zwei Jahre ist so der Christian sagt wenn
du noch einmal Christian sagst vergesse ich mich
atmen also der dessen Name nicht genannt werden
darf
der der sagt ganz klar es ist für Deutschland
nicht möglich mehr als 100.000 Überweisungen am
am am Tag zu [Gelächter] wuppen entschuldigung
ich dachte es wä ein Witz ja na gut vielleicht
kann der Christian dann wirklich nicht anders
ach er darf Christian sagen wir haben der hat
doch schon Möglichkeiten wir haben eine Behörde
heutzutage schon die könnte das machen das ist
so die Bundesagentur ver Arbeit die Familienkassen
die können jetzt schon 65 Millionen Überweisungen
täglich tätigen das ist eine Behörde ist
ausgezeichnet worden auch quasi mit also
als Organisation mit überdurchschnittlichem
Reifegrad das ist also beamtenende Deutsch für
sau geil Moment Moment Moment wenn wir dem
klimageld also Priorität eingeräumt hätten
dann hätten wir es schon ja n klar also
der der Christian genau der also der hat
äh der hat der wollte das eben selber machen
deswegen läuft das jetzt ü das bundeszentral
und die bundeszentral für Steuern die schafft also
jetzt quasi für das klimageld extra eine neue IT
und das dauert eben bis 2025 moment mal aber dann
wäre die erste Auszahlung über das FDP geführte
Finanzministerium von klimageld also kurz vor
der nächsten Bundestagswahl 2025 ich frage mich
wem das wohl in die Hände spielen könnte doch
dem Christian oder nicht also wenn wir da noch
klimageld haben was aber du hast doch Milliarden
in den klimaf gesteckt ja gut also ist mit dem
Klima und transformationsform das ist natürlich
das muss man das ist nicht einfach zu erklären
m brauchen Sie vielleicht irgendwas zum
Darstellen ja super wie hätten Sie eine
Tafel das W nein hilfreich vielleicht so so in der
Größe Tafel Tafel hätte ich nicht könnten sie
es hiermit na gut das das muss dann wohl so
also dann stellen wir uns mal vor der Klima
und transformationsfor also das das ist die
Finanzplanung jetzt von 2024 also ist natürlich
Geld drin in dem forond also haben wir natürlich
also die nicht abgerufenen chonahilfen dann
sind auch vom nationalen und internationalen
emissionshandelgelder drin und natürlich also
einiges an Rücklagen das sind ja s soum P 100
Milliarden 100 Milliarden bei 80 Millionen
Einwohner innen in diesem Land das wäre ja
dann stolz das klimageld von 1250 € pro Bürgerin
t jetzt mal langsam mit den jungen waschbeeren
das ist natürlich einiges muss natürlich
zurück in die Rücklagen und dann bekommmen
jich einiges Geld aus dem Klima voraus das
ist für die Umgestaltung die klimagerechte der
Wirtschaft ja und dann haben wir natürlich auch
noch den heizungsaustausch im Gebäudesektor das
EG dann die energieintensiven Unternehmen nicht
so her hab jetzt schauen Sie sich das mal an wo
ist denn da jetzt das Bauklötzchen fürs klimageld
t gut das muss es ist hoffnungslos er hat Geld für
energieintensive Unternehmen aber nicht für ärmere
Bürger also das ist jetzt populistisch ausgedrückt
nee das ist ja das steht da noch gar nicht fest
was wir aus dem Klima und transformationsfond
heraus überhaupt alles bezahlen was steht denn
fest steht fest dass wir das klimageld darin
nicht fest eingeplant haben Augenblick haben sie
nicht vorhin gesagt doch das ist die entscheidende
Maßnahme ja ja das ist ja auch und und wenn wir
also wenn sind wenn nicht alle Subventionen die
wir daraus zahlen wollen abgerufen werden aus
dem Klima und transformationsfond dann bleibt
vielleicht sogar Geld übrig am Ende und dann
können wir den Bürger in also tatsächlich Geld
auszahlen 2025 wir haben das mal runtergerechnet
also wenn wir da su sumarum also gibt spezielle
also dann sind das etwa das also 3,70 € wenn
wir Glück haben gut dass wir kein Pech haben
habe ich gesagt im ja Herr habbeck ich lade Sie
mal ein sich hineinz veretzen in die BürgerInnen
ja ich versuch das mal können Sie das vielleicht
nachempfinden dass 3,70 € im Jahr sich nicht
wirklich wie eine Entlastung anfühlen ja gut
klar deswegen will ich das klimageld ja jetzt
auch noch nicht auszahlen deswegen ich dachte
wegen Christian nee weil es zu wenig ist also
gut langsam kann ich verstehen warum sie immer
verprügelt werden sehen sie sehen Sie selbst
siehst du selbst unser Therapeut meint du bist
schuld an der AFD ja g steile These da muss ich
ja schon mal Rückfrage stellen dürfen wen das
also so ist W natürlich wieder der kleine Robi
schuld ist ja also warum ist das dann so dass
die Menschen die hier die die die AFD wählen
warum sind dann die nicht sauer wegen zu wenig
Klinger Geld sondern wegen zu viel Migranten
ich fürchte ihre Zeit ist um
[Applaus] Herr von wir haben was vergessen
was denn na das Abo und die Glocke was
dann dann war das hier alles ganz
umsonst ich fürchte ja vielleicht
wissen unsere Zuschauer auch selbst
wo sie abonnieren können dass jetzt
noch zwei weitere Videos gucken können
stimmt unsere Zuschauer sind ja sehr
klug